- Chaque soir est e.e.e.e.e.e.e.
(musique et applaudissements)
Un chant et une danse sont
dé   à chacun des joueurs
pendant le jeu.
Malgré les apparences,
les spectateurs sont attentifs
au déroulement de la partie.
(cris de joie)
l'heure de la danse des points.
♪ ♪ ♪
Quand c'est votre première
expérience du baseball taïwanais
en personne, c'est une ambiance
grisante.
♪ ♪ ♪
Moment magique pour la petite
Shu-Yun qui partageait déjà la
passion de son papa Eddïnan
dans les années 90 pour pouvoir
suivre son équdedede près.
La Ligue CPBL en est à sa
33e saison. Elle se relève desas
sportifs en 1996 et en 2008.
Le gonenenement taïwanais
a même dû intervenir pour
nettoyer le sport.
♪ ♪ ♪
Confiance retrouvée,
les partisans des équipes
adverseséféféféféféféféféféféfé.
♪ ♪ ♪
e e e baseball fait partie
de l'identité taïwanaise.
"C'est le sport national,
une grande fierté."
"On dirait qu'en Amérique,
les gens veulent plutôt prendre
une bière et manger pendant
la partie", ajoute celui-ci.
♪ ♪ ♪
Malgré la chaleur intense,
l'ambiance carnavalesque règne
dans lenenenenenenenenenenenenÇe
déroutant pour les Canadiensete.
♪ ♪ ♪
Il fait très chaud,
c'est humide. Les partisans
ont chanté, ils ont dansé
pendant près de quatre heur
de l'énergie pour recommencer
demain et le surleaiaiain.
Le résultat importe peu,
seul le plaisir.
Ici Philippe LeBlanc,
Radio-Canada, Tainan
dans le sud de l'île de Taïwa